et en guyane ce sont les transports en
commun qui font défaut les taxis
collectifs se font rares pour protester
contre l'arrivée de ligne concurrentes
la gare routière de cayenne la voici le
coin semble à l'abandon
et pourtant tous les jours des centaines
de personnes transitent par ici les
taxis collectifs n'ont pas d'horaire
fixe le départ c'est au moment où le
véhicule est complet pas de règle juste
une bonne dose de patience c'est pas
évident on préfère au moins trois aides
et en boîte en eux et qui arrive ouais
attendre un bus parfois très longtemps
c'est aussi le lot de bon nombre de
jeunes à charge en fonction des
chauffeurs et des embouteillages de la
journée certains usagers et de nombreux
lycéens ont désormais pris l'habitude de
ne plus attendre les transports en
commun les quoi j'ai pas qu'au relais
d'après-midi écoles par exemple si au
final à 10h30 ou neuf heures et où il ne
pas attendre le muscat l'après midi
revoir la politique des transports en
commun un chantier annoncé depuis juin
2006 des infrastructures de la gare
routière aurait dû être remanié
toujours rien à l'horizon